you
I work for Lucas licensing and we handle
all merchandise tied to the star wars
and indiana jones properties right here
we've got Chewbacca slippers uh with you
know fo will Kieffer you know I got to
get me some of these we've got Mickey
Mouse as Luke scholar at Skywalker
x-wing pilot and minnie mouse as
Princess Leia I'm not a skater but uh
yeah we do skateboards this one has yo
donut this right here is Captain Rex
from the new clone wars series these
guys are badass clone he's a clone
captain but in this version he's cuddly
this right here is a Fernandez guitar I
believe it's only available in Japan but
yeah this is this is a fully functional
electric guitar we've got the robot r2d2
so you make our to you know dance by
just using your voice which is pretty
cool I don't know what this is I don't
know if this is actually came out or not
but this one's kind of weird I am dead
just ready for the beaches star wars
beach ball so for those of us who have
had the Millennium Falcon toy as a kid
this is sort of what you wanted that
Millennium Falcon to be the original
designer on that toy 30 years later
implemented all sorts of features that
he would have liked from Cena when he
was a kid this is just yeah just an
amazing an amazing toy that also harkens
back to to the the Millennium Falcon
that we had as kids not every Star Wars
product is going to be before every fan
one example is the they had a lollipop
that was had the head of Jar Jar and the
lolly part part the lollipop part was
with George tongue that just seems like
a just it's too weird too weird for me
not every product fits with the Stars
continuity here's an example darth tater
I think he started off as a joke we've
done star wars transformers we recently
came out with a game soul calibur that
had Star Wars characters in it you know
sometimes continuity be damned you know
some things are just cool